[Music]
I don't want to wait
another
hour I just want to
play the new Fallout for
G in my my heart I have but
one
desire to give all caps to
you for a real pit
[Music]
boy I've lost all ambition to slay the
on CL Henry I can't wait to play in Pre
[Music]
and obtain my new mission to destroy or
to save but I'll rebuild every inch I
explore believe me I don't want to wait
another
hour I just want to
play alongside dog me meet
again to hear that transmission from
Three Dog
again though I might have killed him in
the war three dog's dead that's all I've
got intent of demolition FAL ghouls I
will slay with crafted guns like never
seen before believe me I don't want to
wait toight
another
[Applause]
hour but it's still months
ahead so I'll play shelter
[Music]
[Applause]
instead